life George says the virtues are going
to look into the noble ends in certain
situations whereas Prudence will
deliberate about the means of achieving
those ends just to get that cleared up
yeah I mean that's traditionally the way
that we present it the virtues Orient us
towards and they Orient us not just
cognitively but affectively towards
um the right outcomes the right
intentions and then Prudence is like you
know think about it like each of the
virtues as being sort of like a uh a
boss who knows where things ought to go
and then Prudence comes along and is the
team of employees are like okay great we
got a mandate how are we going to make
this happen in the most efficient way
possible that that's part of what
Prudence is doing so it's looking at
means right
um means to ends but like I said it's
also looking more broadly at like the
situation that you're in and looking at
what what's most important about the
situation what factors you could
you could ignore or downplay you know
Prudence could also be helpful for maybe
bringing up things
um
that you've got sort of in the back your
mind you're like we need to highlight
this right maybe maybe that's part of
what it does again we're going Beyond
Aristotle's own discussion here in in
saying these things
well so George says I wanted to ask how
does Aristotle view the virtues in terms
of the rational
versus the non-rational parts of the
Soul
I'm a little confused about Aristotle's
notion of corrective Justice from last
class so two two different questions
really there and
um so let's talk about the first one the
rational versus the non-rational parts
of the Soul
so earlier on in the nick of McCann
ethics Aristotle talks about us as
having a you can call it desirous or
emotional uh the the Greek word for it
is
the word that we get erecticay from
means something like affectivity or
desire or feeling in general and for
Aristotle
um desires for bodily Pleasures
epithumia they're one kind of a rexus
the the desirous
modality that leads to anger and and
other things connected to that thumos
that's also a form of orexis
um likewise uh what we often translate
is wish or will laces that's that's a
form of a rexus the emotions in general
are types of rexes and so is
um choice deliberative choice or provide
races all of these are par all of these
bear on that that part of the soul that
we actually have in common with animals
because animals are are driven by these
although not by boolasis as such and so
that's that's let's call it the lower
part of the Soul it's not the vegetative
part that handles like respiration and
digestion all these things that we're
not really aware of it's it's an animal
part of the soul and then on top of that
we have the rational part of the Soul
right
and as we're going to see in just a
couple of minutes the rational part of
the soul is actually for Aristotle
divided into two parts
um but what matters as far as the moral
virtues go is they shape and bear upon
the orectike part of the soul and they
make it amenable to listening to the
rational part of the Soul as he says
like a son can obey or listen to his
father and then take you know advice or
orders from from him so the moral
virtues they're informed by the higher
part of the Soul right but they exist
within this desirous affective part of
the Soul
um that is below that in in Aristotle's
ordering and you know the goal is to
sort of integrate these together now
about the corrective Justice right
um we can we could think for example
that maybe you would need to use the
higher part of the soul and and I think
that's that would be quite right
um
in order to figure out how to rectify
things and that would make perfect sense
but the disposition the hexis The Habit
would exist in the lower part of the
Soul this tendency towards doing Justice
this uh you know willingness to to be
just with other people Desiring it
taking pleasure and Justice pain in
Injustice and and corrective Justice is
um you know you could say that
corrective Justice
exists because other forms of Justice
sometimes miss the mark
and we need to like you know if we've
got a distribution that was unfair we
need to fix it somehow and it's also a
way of dealing as we saw before with
criminality where criminals are getting
over on other people and taking more
than their fair share so
we're going to talk about what
deliberation means but that tells you
what kind of affectivity he later on
he's also going to tell us in this very
famous uh passage that it's kind of a
bridge probably racist between to go to
George's question the higher and lower
parts of the Soul
um Prairie racist choice deliberative
choice is we there's two Greek terms
here it's um noose orectike which can be
translated as mind informed by desire
but it's also orexis
desire informed by intellect or mind
right and so it's kind of this bridge
place within us
um he'll also tell us that
um prairaces is the or that the the
guiding you could call it purpose the
hennikatinos of prairasis is orexis
desire Kai logos principle or or
rationality so this is a a really
important
Point not so much about Prudence but
about priorases or choice but it's going
to come back to prudence
but let me take Allison's question right
away and then maybe open it up to some
other ones is it acceptable to map
Aristotle's Soul onto what the cognitive
neuroscientist psychologist May term
Consciousness today or as his concept of
Soul the same as psyche like Plato So
neither and I would say this is this is
kind of a big question
you can't effectively
um take
um uh Aristotle's
um
concept of soul and even map it on to
Plato they're not the same you know for
example Plato has these three parts of
the Soul you know the the uh um rational
part the middle thematic part and then
the other part the desires which are
multiple and stuff like that Aristotle
says those are all rexus so they're not
there isn't like a rational desire in
the rational part of the Soul it's
existing in the erecticay part so
there's some important differences
similarly Aristotle and Plato don't map
neatly onto the stoics and you know
Consciousness is not the same thing as
um
what you could call the soul in ancient
times Consciousness would be a part of
it and I think that the Contemporary
neuroscientists and psychologists are
all over the map I mean if we just stick
with Neuroscience there's not complete
consensus in that field about what
Consciousness is period if we extend it
further to psychology then we've got an
even bigger problem you could say
because there are so many schools of
psychology and they don't all have the
same ideas about things so
um
I don't I think that what you can do is
you can you can try to find sometimes
parallels but you're not going to find
mappings
um you're not going to find complete
coincidences by the way I mentioned too
that this comes up all the time whenever
I teach Freud because you know we Freud
has a tripartite understanding of the
soul and there's something that kind of
seems like Freud's ID in the appetites
and Freud actually says so
but the other two parts of the Soul
Don't map neatly onto what Plato has
going on either develop and to go back
to Allison's uh question about mapping
Aristotle's let's call it his model onto
others
I think that this is in some respects a
more robust model than what a lot of
contemporary psychologists or
neuroscientists are working with and
that's that's part of what I find very
attractive about
Aristotle and his uh moral psychology
myself you know I think that's part of
what attracts a lot of Neo aristotelians
as they get called to this this sort of
account
and let's take the question that George
had so uh does furnaces give moral
commands such as whatever is just is
good so whatever is just as good would
not be a command
as such that would be something more
like a general principle
and that's a great question
um
does frenasis give sort of General
uh principles
yes and no
um
it makes use of them
and you can say well where does it get
those from and maybe the question
um
could be answered by saying other
peoples
fronasis but Aristotle doesn't himself
say that right and so actually to go to
George's question one of the things that
Aristotle says is that Prudence
is not just a matter of the general
right the catholu the universal but also
takes account of particular matters
because action deals with the
particulars so you could have something
I mean I I don't know that that Prudence
would operate with something at the
level of generality of whatever it is
just as good but it could be a little
bit further down if we want to get to
the door opening thing why do we open
doors for people well because we want to
preserve a certain kind of uh etiquette
or we see that they're struggling with
things and we need to get the door open
for them so they can bring in all the
packages
and we might go through some like you
know do some general ideas and then
there's the specific case because we
could also have like somebody come to
the door and we're like I'm not opening
the door for that jerk you know he never
opens the door for me I'm going to send
him a message right that could also be a
matter of of prudence as well
and Aristotle says that Prudence is
concerned with integrating both the
general and the particular things doing
that well
um now does he give us advice about
exactly how we do that no and that is
one of the
um uh issues with his his discussions of
prudence it's kind of underdetermined
you could say he tells us that um
or understanding is concerned with
things that we can doubt about and
deliberate about and it's concerned with
the same things as Prudence but it's not
quite the same thing as prudence
why well Prudence is point or end the
the goal of of having Prudence is to
provide statements and this kind of goes
to George's question about
um giving moral commands prudence's end
is a statement about what we ought to do
or ought not to do either generally or
in this particular situation and so it
does give orders
um the Greek term for that is uh epitoc
Decay like lays down things that we we
should do it arranges things you could
say
um
but understanding just makes judgments
uh he says kritike Monon so a judgment
is not quite the same thing yet as an
order you could say that in order the
process of creating an order uses
judgment but it's not exactly the same
thing as a judgment
so understanding doesn't actually mean
having or getting Prudence as he says
but it it's connected with it so he says
we're wrapping this up let me take
Allison's question about the natural
virtues so
are they genetic or inherited things
I mean Aristotle doesn't have a
conception of genetics
um he does have a conception of
temperament
um in a very broad sense right which
which can be determined to some degree
by the bodily humors within us obviously
he has a whole different conception of
medicine and physics than than we do but
if he were around in the present I think
he would he probably would view these as
like genetic or having having their
their origins in our nature
um you know for example you know things
often do run in families and the
causality gets very complicated right if
you grow up with somebody so I'll just
give you an example from my family right
and I and I'll give you two examples so
I'm adopted in both my
um biological family families of origin
and in my adopted family on my mother's
side there is a lot of bipolar disorder
my um
my birth mother suffers from that and a
number of other things
um
my adopted Mother's family my great my
uncle aim
um was severely bipolar many of my
cousins are bipolar my mom was manic
um my my adopted mom she only got the
one side of it and so you know you could
say well
um
I I'm not bipolar but I but I suffer
from depression is that is that in part
caused by
my genetics or the family that you're
involved in or by other factors it's
it's complex right
um similarly I kind of got the the
double whammy when it came to anger and
a Rask ability right I mean I've got a
uh dad who a biological dad who wound up
becoming a police chief after doing a
whole bunch of other policing things uh
and being in the Army and stuff like
that and he he you know he was a pretty
aggressive guy back in the day right
um and that made him good at some of the
things that he did but it also you know
showed a tendency towards aggression and
stuff like that some of that might be
genetic that might be why I was
attracted as were also my uh
half-brother and sister to going into
the army all of us went in the army
um
and you know you could also get some
stuff from your your family that you're
growing up with so I think maybe
temperament is a complicated thing that
that could involve genetics but also
could involve mimesis patterning after
people and there may be other factors
involved as well now those would give us
these natural virtues or perhaps natural
vices right
um somebody could be badly off with
respect to anger because of their
genetics because of the family that they
grow up in where everybody yells at each
other at the drop of a hat
um and then so following up with the
second part then we grow them or
diminish them intellectually or morally
through learning prudently that's
exactly it I think as far as Aristotle
is concerned
Prudence by itself won't pull that off
but with other things like you know
Role Models
um some degree of Education you know
whatever else practicing whatever else
we want to throw in there
and we're probably when it comes to
these matters kind of badly off in our
society in part because we often do
treat virtues as if there's something
just natural like you just have them or
you don't have them right whereas
Aristotle thinks that they require a lot
of work and cultivation so that's a
really important
um thing to ask about you know
get those done okay so George uh has a
good good question can the environment
shape our Prudence in right or wrong
ways such as rewarding certain vices too
much contrary to ignoring certain
virtues in our society so I don't think
that that would be shaping prudence
um it would be instead like fostering
certain vices right
um or making it difficult to not just
practice certain virtues but maybe even
know what they are right so if if you
grew up in let's just take one example
you grow up in a Super Macho society as
as a man right you're probably going to
have
a screwed up set of dispositions with
respect to anger with respect to courage
you're probably going to be more rash
than courageous
and maybe some other things as well you
know maybe conspicuous consumption leads
to intemperance
um maybe a lack of generosity or being
spendthrift or things like that right so
the society could be getting in the way
not only of developing the virtues but
even understanding what a virtuous
disposition as opposed to a vicious
disposition would look like because
remember people who are vicious often
think that they're The Virtuous ones
right so if your whole society is like
somebody got in your face kick their ass
you know and you get that message over
and over and over again which I got as a
kid
um you're probably going to
um
be badly off and vicious now does does
that get in the way of prudence yes but
not in quite a direct way
so remember that Prudence has to do with
the particulars and also with the
generalities and also with the last or
ultimate things right so
um
Prudence requires some development you
you know if you have a bad Society
you might not have any models of people
who are actually prudent although that's
probably not the case because even bad
societies have some people who hold
things together
so there's probably some but it probably
takes you a lot more work to get at them
so you know if you have kind of you know
jackasses as your mom and dad and family
you're not you're gonna be worse off
most likely but then again as
adolescents you could have somebody
who's quite prudent actually even I'll
not just as adolescents for people like
me well into your 20s you could have
people who are very prudent and you
should have been smart enough to
recognize them as prudent and you wrote
them off you know I think about some of
my professors you know one of the guys
who gave me the best advice is somebody
who I only took one class with and
didn't spend an awful lot of time with
Tom Alexander but looking back on it he
was the most fronimos the most
practically wise person that I knew in
the department and he did give me
helpful advice at one time
I'm there Nicole says how do you deal
with people who are misguided at work
they slack off and don't produce good
quality work well it depends on what
your uh situation is in relation to them
so if those people are reporting to you
there you've got a little bit of power
that you could you could exercise right
you could say listen your performance is
not up to uh the standards that we
expect I'm going to coach you and we're
going to write this down you know
documentation and you better start
performing a little bit better right and
maybe that'll work and maybe it won't
right sometimes you have to fire people
after you do that if it's a co-worker
it's a bit tougher right it's not like
you have any any uh power over them you
can say things like I don't appreciate
when you don't do your work because
you're making more work for me but I
mean this is where the stoics have
things right you don't control what the
other person does as a response so
dealing with is in part what what you
can do on your part and you know you
could you could also look at your own
responses to them are you getting like
really pissed off with them
or envious about the fact that they're
getting away with things you can say
well I don't I don't want to be
constantly feeling these negative
emotions
how can I look at this situation in ways
that protect me and and allow me to
function within the workplace
even though everybody else isn't doing
everything that they're supposed to be
doing that would be my
General suggestions but you know these
are this is where we get into the
particulars right are they slacking off
because they're the boss's nephew and
they they got put in there are they
slacking off because they're kind of a
lazy person who's never done good work
wherever they are are they slacking off
because the workplace is screwed up and
they were a good employee once but now
they're kind of burnt out or disengaged
which you know some people estimate is
about 40 percent of the current American
workplace that was pre-coveted too by
the way
um these are all different kinds of
situations right there's probably not
much you can do about the boss's nephew
um but somebody who's burned out maybe
you can find ways to get there there as
we say their head back in the game right
um so it's gonna the tahecosta the
particulars are going to be very
important in situations like that
these lines
um Allison says may it be fair to
suggest the rational part of our soul
may not develop till at least our late
20s maybe there's a correlation with
brain development yeah I think for
Aristotle uh there definitely is
he didn't know that the brain
um was doing the thinking he thought the
heart does it
he thought the brain was something like
a radiator
um helping to cool the blood you know
and uh
but you know he does have kind of a a
bodily or somatic understanding of how
things work so like anger for example he
says this in the the on the soul can be
understood physically as a boiling of
blood around the heart it can be
understood psychologically as a desire
to impose suffering in in in a return
retaliation and these these all kind of
come together right so yeah the capacity
to actually
fully because it's not as if as if uh
teenagers can't reason at all right but
to to fully practically reason
um maybe it is dependent to some degree
on brain development we do know that
like the decision making centers of the
brain are not fully developed until like
the mid-20s doesn't mean that they don't
exist of course right
um because kids make decisions and carry
out prioritizations but
they're not they're not as
um fully developed as somebody in their
their late 20s I think there's clearly
something there Aristotle does point out
this is a Nico McCain ethics book one
that
um aging by itself does not
automatically provide maturity there's a
lot of immature older people right
um but there is something to this bodily
development going on and a lot of the
factors that that all of you been
bringing up you know environment what
our homes look like the kind of
workplaces we have our education and you
know in public education or private
education whatever you have going on all
of these well in our general culture
what what it is that we're getting to
see on you know TV on our phones all of
those play important roles in shaping us
to some degree so I think these are some
very important factors and we could say
that part of being prudent would be
realizing
um how these factors work on us and
deciding you know what we're going to
allow and what we're what we're not
right maybe there's some things that it
would be prudent and not to watch all
that much right maybe it would be
prudent to
say I want to listen to these people but
I'm not going to pay attention to what
these people have to say you know
but I I kind of think a lot of these I
don't think Prudence is like an on off
switch
I think it's like the ver the other
moral virtues it's something that you
can have more or
less of and that you know we don't want
to be perfectionist about this because
if we are we're going to be dismaying
because we don't have complete Prudence
I mean I'm not a completely prudent
person myself and I've been studying
Philosophy for you know in academic ways
for 32 years
um but I'm better off than I certainly
was when I first started and I think
probably most of you can say similar
things about your own study of
philosophy or maybe all of you can
that'd be wonderful if you can but you
know we're not
we're not uh
Gods who who get everything right all
the time
was helpful for you George you say
you've got a light bulb moment yeah I I
think it is a digression too I think
it's very important in general in
philosophy
and I think this can extend to other
things like psychology as well
um we want to consider examples this is
this is a very important way of
making sense of things we we've got a
general theory and then we think about
well what would that look like here you
know how would that play out in the
workplace in in my relationship with my
dad in my relationship with uh this pet
that I have or things along those lines